la verità è che a casa mia iniziato a
fare freddo abissale non so per quale
motivo e sto indossando il maglione più
antisesso della vita per assicurarsi
almeno ho caldo grazia di dio
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono farisei e oggi siamo tornati suo
happy with che tra l'altro adesso che ci
penserà bari settimane non lo faceva
ormai alterno tra e più di sei under
simulator riuscivo a fare un gameplay
decente almeno una volta in uno dei due
lasciamo perdere i skybox partiamo
subito che sono col cazzo che che faccio
gameplay del centro estero come fa se va
bene come dovrei uscire la storia va ma
spiegami frate allora ti non so che
scuola hai fatto roveggia probabile
punto ria si studiano le proporzioni
nelle cose come cazzo ci passo io là
dentro ma neanche con 800 bottiglie di
vitasnella entrò in quel buco ho capito
adesso perché sono poco studiato quindi
devo devo far passare tutta la scatola
fuori
rischiate perché io sto giocando sta
roba soprattutto farà il mio problema
però quasi fatta ragazze presenti io
devo spostare tutta scatola fuori è la
cosa più geniale che io abbia mai visto
c'era ho fatto a me [ __ ] soldi e tutto
quanto grazie e magari anche una gamma
nuova se vi avanza survive box rain
sopravvivi alla pioggia di bottiglie è
mio culo che mi parla dalle bottiglie
ragazzi il culo di ferro questa era
comunque un livello molto più
intelligente dei soliti che faccio kick
boxe ce l'abbiamo ragazzi con le scatole
questo episodio non so perché ma va bene
ok
beh no non sa che hanno fatto ma perché
qual è il problema che non riesce a
centrare le scatole santo iddio
io ho carenza di livelli che mi
interessa execution al ram page vuota fa
bello il tipo è un figo raga complimenti
immaginatevi che il tipo sia vostra
nonna e immaginatevi che alla fine del
livello ci siate voi prima di iniziare a
livello chiamate vostra non ne dite
non ho aperto il frigo e non c'è niente
da mangiare questa è la reaction quello
credo fosse un nipote di passaggio
perché se non si bloccherebbe neanche
una volta la nonna comunque è una strage
ma non ho capito il perché di questa
cosa non è
[Musica]
è la madonna è in realtà voi eravate
quello raga purtroppo non è che stavate
messi male a livello di grandi di cibo
però battleship extreme 2
proviamo sta roba ragazzi giusto per
capire se ne vale la pena ma a quanto
pare non ne vale la pena gioco di merda
world trofei terzi ma come ci sono gli
haters in questo episodio è più la ex
moglie quindi la mia ex dovrebbe essere
un mio iter non credo fosse le mie prime
non questa va bene kid killer da assi
quello el'iter medioera tacking duel
ok il suo insegnante ma dai video tratto
ci somiglia anche da adesso ci penso che
la stai facendo prof
sapevo che era un porco maniaco ok
baldini che cade limite cade il mic e cà
di nì checa degli impiegati picnic cadi
perfetto
ok allora prossimo sitter beh ho vinto
non capisco il senso di sti livelli
ragazzi ma chi se ne frega andiamo
avanti se no hi fi t rex sarebbe quello
che è nostra ferma geniale sarebbe tipo
io per per farlo saltare devo cliccare
lo schermo no vabbè fantastico che se in
realtà ragazzi e la scheda non so se mi
è mai successo ma è la schermata che
compare quando google chrome non ha
internet bellissimo non ha un senso ma
va bene texture playing the move per
prego slobo atoms ecco io ho bisogno di
ancora più rallenti per capire che cosa
sta succedendo sulla non riesco a
muovermi ma come cazzo si fa la regala
impossibile
cazzo ma è impossibile vincere li becca
in testa ma questo stimato 9 non ci
credo sono morto ma come sono morto
perché possono vivo stavolta sono vivo
stato sono vivo sono sicuramente vivo
giro si sta all'ares non ci credi ok va
bene raccomandato in schermo interno io
sono frasi le devo dire soubirous
installer
non ci posso credere congratulation
juvara file top secret di ghezzal è ok
ho vinto un laptop cosa c'entra una tipa
mezza nuda non ho capito ma va bene
messo a lato un virus del mio livello
preparati per vederlo
[Musica]
forse da tanto tempo il livello più
bello che abbia mai visto da tanto e non
faccio musica apra romani a livello di
capra romania poco fi card grazie capra
romania siamo ritornati borgaccio ai a
mahler padre co sto facendo incredibile
romania porta milia di sfigati perché si
chiama capra romania scrive chi è che
l'ha chiamato caprona bene ok italiani
vi pice in bocca parla [ __ ] sapevo
capra romania dove si casi gabra romani
arena liti kick soccer
proviamo a vedere bello oddio zaza
uguale
non si può fare la stessa cosa che
riuscito a fare zaza ai mondiali molto
meglio li mortacci mia come ho fatto per
noi di chi vai tu bravo bravo miyake
rischiato di segnare non si sa come
questa roba
cos'era oddio mi dire che si è fermato
così non ci voglio credere ma veramente
a va quindi devo tirare con barra
spaziatrice ho capito non avevo capito
oddio oddio magari il fantastico basta
rigore più bello della vita voglio farne
un altro
minchia bellissima però dovrebbe star
calmi ma vocali rock swing games su
chiede rock swing è inscritto porca eva
magari non mi faccio domande gioco che
dite troppo da ieri oltre a ok perfetto
bravo zio esattamente la posizione
double trovo questa non avere dubbi
probabilmente mi aveva anche scritto di
fare attenzione a come finivo giu mario
sono trash che non lo ascolto bene anche
questa è la posizione double draw di ma
anche una gamba non ci arrivo no ma cosa
facevo ok perfetto ciò ancora una palla
io c'è ancora una palla prendetevela
sesta roba santo iddio
bellissimo ora sono 130 episodi che
faccio è più vi sono ancora non sono
iscritto matti mettere ai cinque stelle
solo per l'idea prossimo all 87 per
cento ma facciamo un imposti col che era
una vita non ne faccio uno e ci sarà un
motivo
che dite spiedino di teste no va bene
purché non ci credo come cazzo fatto a
morire ma come ha fatto era arrivato
alla fine non è possibile fa quarta
sfida va dai porca vacca no raga in una
parola ma come si fa a morire così non è
per caso il livello più sfortunato che
ho fatto negli ultimi 130 episodi c'è
veramente ho finito il livello ma muoio
lo stesso
sarebbe dovuta andare così tutte le
volte però non so come non è andata così
va bè youtubers life è vero è vero posso
confermare tutte le giornate degli
youtubers iniziano con un vetro in testa
crea uno io ci ruba come l'ex coach
usare i cieli un cappello questo cerco
di farlo youtuber più simile a me
ragazzi quindi facciamo abbastanza c'è
ottima scelta grazie chiusa skin non
sono razzista ma io sono veramente una
mozzarella ok
wow amazing perché sennò nero mi dicevi
amiga questo gioco la razzista giosa
clothing lo fanno apposta quella fino al
risultato finale vediamo se sono simili
abbastanza va bene scegliere le views e
gli iscritti ma cosa ovviamente uno si
fa a scegliere 2003 cede e certo che uno
sceglie l'ultima sono convinto io sono
esattamente la via di mezzo tra sti due
però non c'è quindi scelgo il mio domani
ok bello guarda sono più
non c'è dubbio adventures che animazione
bella degna dei film più famosi al mondo
tipo avatar
bello se è ayane non è mai una bella
giornata quando prendi un tronco in
piena faccia però ok essere lato
dall'altro non facciamoci domande basta
che facevi tecnico
meno male che ho vinto perché la
situazione era messa leggermente in modo
tragico escape the maze ragazzi facciamo
l'ultimo non sanno cosa dice eh vabbè ma
cove 9 dai ragazzi chiudiamo con questo
che era il livello di partenza vediamo
se riesco a farlo decentemente in
confronto con la l'inizio era era un
gioco da ragazzi porca eva la vocazione
sbagliato di qua misano ma [ __ ]
pure non fa una piega zio mi servirebbe
vincere grazie perfetto va bene ragazzi
episodi di oggi più intelligente del
solito ma sarà la felpa e sarà quello
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa mi
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche ai
vari social che condivido con
descrizione decidevano prossimo livello
di hoepli magari con un bestiario un po
più adeguato anzi appassionato porto
anche il cappello da coniglio che fa
sempre il suo effetto va bene ragazzi